Joining me now is Raymond Ibrahim. He is
someone that I've been reading for a
long time and I want to thank Khadija
for getting him on the broadcast with us
tonight. Raymond, welcome to the
broadcast. Thanks for being here.
Hi Brandon, great to be with you. Great
to have you on. We have been talking
I've been I've been reading your stuff
for so long and wanting to talk to you
for so long. So we're so happy you're
here. Thank you for that. All right.
>> My pleasure. Let's talk if we can about
and I'm going to I'm going to promote
your website. Let's go ahead and do that
now by the way.
There it is. Raymond Ibrahim, see how
it's spelled folks, dot com. It's that
easy, okay? And we have some of his
books. I'll even just show you some of
his books real quick. Here you go.
Two Swords of Christ. The Defenders of
the West. So many others, right? Check
them all out. The Al-Qaeda Reader. In
fact, let's start with that. Let's start
with that right there.
Tell me about Al-Qaeda, will you?
Because I know we went into Afghanistan
supposedly to eradicate Al-Qaeda, but
everything I'm listening and learning,
Al-Qaeda seems to be stronger now more
than ever. I'm also hearing from
some former intelligence people that the
bin Laden sons
are very busy planning terrorist attacks
on America, that Al-Qaeda has a very
detailed plan
to kill a lot of Americans much bigger
than 9/11. Multiple multiple guys in a
squad hitting multiple places, multiple
soft targets
in one day and it will last for several
days. Now back in you go on our website
worldviewtube.com
and I know my audience is hearing me
repeat this, but I want Raymond to hear
it because he doesn't know. It's my
first time interviewing him. But going
back to 2008, we were warning about a
terrorist attack in America like what
happened in Beslan with the killing of
over 300, most of them children in the
former Soviet Union. And we've been
warning since 2008 about soft targets
like schools and
it was called the perfect day was what
the scenario was called. And now I'm
hearing from some former intelligence
people that are openly talking about it
on X that they're concerned about the
bin Laden boys and Al-Qaeda and that
they have terror cells here in the US,
that they're here and they have a plan
and it's going to be basically like an
October 7th attack here in the United
States, which I Again, on October 7th,
we heard Hamas saying we're going to do
this again and again and take it to the
US. What are your thoughts on that?
How's that fit with your book on your
own website on the Al-Qaeda Reader?
Yeah, actually it fits in very well.
That book which is actually my first
book, so it's good that we start there.
We just started writing 2005 about 20
years ago and it came out in 2007 was
basically based on the writings of
Al-Qaeda, primarily Osama bin Laden and
also Ayman al-Zawahiri, his number two,
but who eventually became number one
until he also got killed. And it was
their basically their theological
worldview and up until that point we had
only been exposed to their propaganda,
which the Western media was only too
happy to
to disseminate, which was basically
we're attacking you, we're killing you
because we have grievances. You started
it. You started it and and the list went
from the Crusades to colonialism to
Israel to, you know, teddy bears named
Muhammad. I mean, it went on and on, but
you found out in the theological tract
and this kind of gets to why Al-Qaeda is
still alive. Their arguments that they
presented, their theological doctrinal
arguments against the infidel were such
that they really transcend Al-Qaeda. In
other words, they're the same arguments
that ISIS uses, the same arguments that
Hamas uses, Boko Haram in Nigeria,
al-Shabaab and all of these things. So
the point is you come to learn that
the hate-filled jihadist teachings are
not articulated by Al-Qaeda. They are
not the authors of it, which is why you
can kill Osama bin Laden, you can kill
Ayman al-Zawahiri, you can kill this or
that leader. The idea doesn't go away.
The organizations morph and shift into
each other and one grows out of another
one, but they all have the same
underlying worldview, which of course
goes back centuries to the founding of
Islam itself and the teachings of the
prophet of Islam, Muhammad.
So I think that's ultimately that's if
you want to understand what you what you
were mentioning, the threat to the US
and to anyone in general, that's really
it. It's you know, these teachings are
not byproducts of Al-Qaeda. This is how
they've often been presented in the
Western media, unfortunately, that if
you I remember when Osama bin Laden
died, all these, you know, leading CNN
analysts said the war on terror is over.
We got the bad guy. Yeah, well, the
ideas transcend the bad guy because
they're integral to the religion and the
jihadist worldview.
So would you be shocked Raymond that
we see one day a
October 7th style attack here in the US
where we have churches, mosques,
hospitals, schools,
theaters, restaurants hit.
Soft targets. Would you Would you be
shocked if that kind of thing is in play
as some retired national security people
are saying?
No, not at all. You know, ISIS, the
Islamic State, which is the more most
forthright of these terrorist
organizations,
has called specifically and precisely
for that. And you know, the small the
small scale attacks that are not as big
as what you're describing, but that
happen all the time, especially in
Europe, is when you know, some Muslim
just gets up and crashes his truck or
car into a crowd or whatever, just like
happened at the synagogue in Manchester
a couple weeks ago and comes out and
stabs people. That happens with alarming
frequency and it's often in direct
response to these ISIS communiques that
people in the West never hear about
where they tell them specifically go out
as the arm of the Islamic State,
terrorize the infidels. They quote key
Quranic verses like Quran 9:5, which
says slay the, you know, the infidels,
the idolaters wherever you find them.
Okay? And um and they
and long story short, no, of course I
would not be surprised. And of course
we've had bigger attacks. We've had, you
know, the 9/11 itself. So what you're
describing,
that's actually a smaller scale than
what we've already had and what we are
currently having all around because you
have all these so-called lone wolf lone
wolf terrorists and they can accomplish
a lot, especially if they work together.
And they're out there and they're
radicalized, as the saying goes, by ISIS
and by Islamic scriptures of the
jihadist nature anyway. And so really,
you know, their imagination is the limit
what how and and how to terrorize and
kill infidels. And I if they can come up
with that kind of means, these terrorist
types, why not? They will. How many of
these folks
that are these imams and leaders of of
Islam
are responding to our
invasion of Afghanistan? In other words,
did the war on terror make it worse? Did
the war so-called war on terror just
create more terrorists? And in one sense
by
you know, killing
so many over there, invading them over
there. Because I'm also hearing they
want to come here and kill in
communities where there are a lot of
retired veterans and make them, those
retired veterans, feel the way they felt
when we invaded their country. Do you
think the war on terror actually has
backfired?
Yeah, the war on terror, you know,
I'm old enough because it's been going
on what, since 2001? So I've been
following it since the start and I
honestly don't know what are the good
benefits that have come out of it. Okay?
All I've seen is things get worse
wherever the US goes and and to be
honest with you, you know, every single
almost every single US president up
until even Donald Trump is one way or
another often times involved in being
supportive of these terrorist groups who
are presented as
you know, freedom fighters. So you know,
you're speaking of Al-Qaeda, the guy
Ahmed al-Sharaa, I believe, who's the
president, the new president of Syria.
Well, he's Al-Qaeda. And you know,
Donald Trump met him and shook hands
with him and told and said he's a tough
guy and he's going to hopefully, you
know, bring us a new start. So the
bottom line is, you know, wherever these
terrorist groups arise
and then you have the violence and then
somehow or other the United States gets
involved
and it all just gets worse, but more
specifically and you saw this, you know,
ISIS ISIS was originally freedom
fighters in Iraq and Syria and then they
became what they what they became. So I
think that's the big price of trying to
sort of ally with for whatever purposes
these groups, but more specifically when
people talk about the war on terror, I
think you're referring to Afghanistan.
That was of course the specific and
what's the end of that? I just know that
we pulled out rather ignominiously under
Joe Biden and
what's changed? I mean, what is is is is
Afghanistan now a democracy and no
longer a patriarchy? No, I mean, it's
identical to how it was before, the same
feelings of those people, which is which
would be considered very conservative
Islam and the same, you know, disdain
for the West. It's all the same after
all that blood and treasure. So
the long and short of it is, you know, I
have a very dim view of sort of Western
interference in these countries. Not
that they shouldn't interfere, but just
the way it's been done so far has
definitely been not very productive and
in fact counterproductive. Mhm. Let me
play a clip for you. I know I've played
it several times for my audience. It's
only a minute and 13 seconds long, but I
want you to see it because I want to ask
you what happened to the President Trump
of his first term
to the President Trump you just
referenced who was calling the president
of Syria a good-looking guy, handsome
guy, strong guy, calling the president
of Turkey in the Oval Office last week a
a good man, a strong man. I'm like,
what what happened to this Donald Trump?
When he was running for president the
first time and in his first term, take a
listen. There's a Muslim problem in the
world. But you do believe overall there
is a Muslim problem in the world.
>> is a Muslim problem, absolutely. You
just have to turn on your television
set. I think Islam
hates us. Did you mean all 1.6 billion
Muslims? I mean a lot of them. You look
at what's happening with the Quran.
Uh it's a pretty scary thing. There's
something there
that teaches some very negative vibe.
They do not respect us at all. Large
portions of a group of people Islam
Large portions want to use very, very
harsh means. You have more than a
handful of moderate Muslims, but you
certainly have a problem with Muslims.
If you have people coming out of mosques
with hatred
and with death in their in their eyes
and and on their minds, we're going to
have to do something.
>> They're trying to take over our children
and convince them how wonderful ISIS is
and how wonderful Islam is
>> [music]
>> and we don't know what's happening. And
we have to look at the Muslims and we
have to do something. We cannot stand by
and be the stupid people while our
country is destroyed. I want
surveillance of certain mosques, okay?
Ibrahim, [snorts]
what do you think happened to that
Donald Trump? Cuz I agree with so much
of that. I'm sure you do as well, right?
Yeah, yeah, that that that's the old
refreshing Donald Trump who who made so
many people love him and vote for him.
And yeah, and that's not the Donald
Trump of today, obviously.
Something changed. You know, it's funny
because I remember he also another thing
you could have added to that collage is
he used to say that Obama Barack Obama
was the founder of ISIS. And he had a
legitimate point because of course ISIS
arose under Obama and Hillary Clinton's
Secretary of State's tenure.
And you know, so there was obviously
something there and it's even worse than
that when you really get into it, but
you know, what is he now with Syria?
The way he's treating this Ahmad
al-Sharaa of of Syria. So it's again,
it's it's just this unwavering thing,
you know, goes back to Reagan and
the Mujahideen who became al-Qaeda.
That's just unfortunate and why but why
he has changed the way you know, he I
mean he everything he said as
politically incorrect as it was in that
clip you just played was fair and
accurate and I think a lot of Americans
agreed with that. But for him now to you
know, just change like that, I don't
know.
Well, and then on top of that, he's
added a
some very troubling people to his
advisory board.
Here's one from the even the Economic
Times, ex-jihadist with al-Qaeda
Lashkar-e-Taiba
links joins Trump's religious
freedom advisory board. Two former US
jihadists who trained these terror camps
in Pakistan have been appointed to the
White House advisory board of lay
leaders under Donald Trump. Ismael Royer
convicted for supporting terror
activists including attacks in Kashmir.
And the other one is Sheikh Hamza Yusuf,
co-founder of the US Muslim College
faces criticism for alleged extremist
links.
I mean,
what are why are these people on his
I mean, really seriously?
Religious freedom? Do you think these
guys are really for religious freedom,
Raymond?
No, I don't. I don't know. Again, very
troubling developments on the Trump
administration's part, you know, why
something like that would even be
happening. It's to me it's I mean, I
don't I don't want to enter into the
realm of conspiracy theories, but it's
pretty inexplicable at this point. Do
you think it's one of the issues of
follow the money? If you have
Trump golf course and resort being built
in Qatar and you've got his son-in-law,
wasn't his son-in-law bailed out with
his building on 666 Fifth Avenue, New
York with his
with by the Qataris? Don't you have
Steve Bannon, wasn't he somehow involved
financially with Qatar? You got the the
Arab states involved in you know,
financial dealings. I mean, at what
point is it follow the money?
Yeah, I mean money definitely buys a lot
of goodwill. So
that could very well explain this sudden
shift. I'm actually surprised about
those two recruits that you just pointed
out. I wasn't even aware of that.
But that again is just uh
it's just it's just funny because Trump
is somehow, you know, the guy who was
going to drain the swamp is you know, in
a way starting to act the way the swamp
has always acted. Mhm. And I don't like
doing shows like this cuz I I've been a
a big supporter of him and Yeah, me too.
I just but I have that's my job. My job
is to present the truth. You know, I'm
not a shill for anybody. Um So I I I
need disappoints me to have to do this.
I don't want to do this. I'd love to
report next week that he's these people
off the board and and had a change of
heart on all of this and gone back to
being the Donald Trump of the clips we
played. Um let's talk about America.
We have the growth of Islam. It's it's
it's growing so fast. And we hear
President Trump holding meetings in the
White House, which I appreciate on
Antifa and the Marxist and what they're
doing and disrupting their funding.
And talking about studying the
financials to find out who's funding
these anarchist and Marxist
revolutionaries.
I say thank you, President Trump. I
agree 100%.
That's one reason why so many people
voted for you.
Because we we thought you would do that
and you've you're doing that. That's
what we're being told.
But what about the other side of the
red-green axis, the green, the Islamist
side? Why are we not
I mean, we're going to label Antifa a
terrorist domestic terrorist
organization, why not Muslim
Brotherhood? Why not go after all of the
money they're bringing into the US and
all of these mosques they're funding?
Like my friend Dave Gaubatz who I
interview regularly who's gone
undercover in 425 mosques in America.
Most of these are funded by
countries that do not wish us well.
Why is he so focused on the Marxist side
but not the Islamist side? I guess it
goes back to maybe
the issue of money. I don't know.
But what about
um
the the the longevity for our country?
We can't see these groups growing and
expanding the way they are. They've
taken down pretty much Michigan. They've
taken down Minnesota.
They're targeting [clears throat] Texas.
They're now targeting my home state of
Tennessee.
How much time do we have left? And if
President Trump's not going to do it, do
we really think another administration
will?
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, well to your first point about you
know, um
this cozying up again to these
organizations. If you really want to
look at the the ultimate example, of
course, is you know, Donald Trump and
all American presidents very close ties
with Saudi Arabia. Mhm. And I say that
because Saudi Arabia is the home of
radicalization. Okay, objectively
speaking, they are the ones who fund,
disseminate, print all the radical
literature that ends up in all these
Western mosques. They are the ones who
are they call them Wahhabis, which means
they're Salafists, which means they're
literalists. Okay,
I remember I translated some years back
that to to show the point that after
some Western diplomat, I think it was
Tony Blair or something went and danced
with the you know, Saudis and holding
swords. And then there's a little fatwa
on a government-funded website,
government
connected website of Saudi Arabia
teaching a standard Islamic doctrine
about how you have to hate non-Muslims
with all your heart even if they're good
to you, even if you you know, they they
want to help you.
This is the doctrine of al-wala'
wal-bara' and it comes from the Quran.
And it just goes on and on and on. So
this is the government on the one hand
saying this, telling their citizens
this. And then on the other hand, you
know, our leaders and theirs meet and
you know, exchange money and favors and
whatever. And you know, it's it's just
ridiculous because this is like I said
to me the head of the snake, the
financial head. You know, you have to
have a financial source for
radicalization and it is Saudi Arabia.
They're just filthy rich because of oil,
okay? And they are the ones if you go to
Pakistan, if you go to Somalia, the
literature there is often more nine
times out of 10 coming from Saudi
Arabia. Okay, the the radical
literature. So that's just you know, one
example.
As far as you know, what's happening in
here in in the United States, Muslims
etc. etc. I mean, the thing is though,
you have to look at at the law.
I mean, if the law allows this, you
know, Islam is treated like a regular
religion and we have freedom of
religion. You can't discriminate, okay?
So as long as it has that that
protection, you know, I think that one
can complain about Muslim growth in the
US, but legally speaking, I don't think
much can be done unless something is
done to the definition of religion
itself and how Islam does or does not
fit into that category. Mhm. Um let's
talk about the number of Christians that
are being murdered by
Islamists.
We've got Nigeria. Here's an October 5th
article. Christians are being wiped out
in Nigeria
as millions faith face death.
Um
there's very little talk about this on
the media here in America. I don't see
any college students protesting or
holding parades in protest
or sit-ins for these Christians. Huh.
Yeah, for some reason these black lives
don't matter.
And I think it's because they're
Christian
and
they don't fit the narrative. They don't
you know,
it's a double whammy because it makes
Muslims look bad and it makes Christians
look good and the media is never going
to support that narrative, okay? Both of
it is bad for them.
But yeah, it's definitely this has been
going on. I think the most recent
estimate, I don't know, maybe 70 to
80,000 Christian Nigerians have been
killed for their faith. And I think the
number, you know, going back maybe 10,
12, 15 years. And I think the number,
the well-documented number is what a
Christian dies is killed every 2 hours
on average. Okay, so 12 every single
day. You'd think this would be a story.
Okay, but it's not, obviously, because
the the media is agenda-driven. And like
I said, this doesn't meet their agenda.
And Nigeria is really the tip of the
iceberg. It's it's a very graphic,
carnage-filled tip. But if you go into
the Islamic world in general, you're
going to see
in Africa, it's the same all over in
Mozambique and in Democratic Republic of
Congo and all around sub-Saharan Africa,
Christians are being massacred. Okay,
and literally genocide. And you're not
hearing about it, but even in other
Islamic countries that are supposedly
moderate. Even Indonesia, supposedly the
most moderate Islamic country, you will
find Christians are being persecuted.
You know, there's a lot of pressure on
their places of worship. Churches are
being banned, are not allowed to, you
know,
be registered. And again, going back to
give you an example about Saudi Arabia,
our good friend and ally, you can't even
have a single church there. Right?
And and when they find Christians
huddled and celebrating Christmas, they
arrest them. Okay, so I mean, think
about it. That is our friend and ally.
What do you expect going to happen?
>> [clears throat]
>> Let's take a look at this article
written by you.
England's St. George Flag
Forged in History's Crusades, Reborn in
Today's Jihads.
September 10th, 2025.
We see people being arrested for
flying this flag in the UK. Tell me the
history of this flag, what it means, and
why is it being flown by so many today,
particularly in the face of
Muslims taking over UK?
Yeah, that's the irony of it. A lot of
English folk are rallying to it because
it's their flag. It's their oldest
national flag. And it has a cross on
white. But what most people don't know,
including some English, is that it
actually goes way back and it was it was
forged in the same context of what's
happening today. It was actually a
crusader flag and red red meant
martyrdom. I'm going to fight and defend
the Christian faith and die. And white
meant I'm trying to live a pure
Christian life. And it really starts
with the Knights of the Temple. But it
actually, so what was it for? It was it
was developed to fight Muslims there.
Okay, in the Holy Land. But then today,
people don't realize that it the same
very flag, people are rallying to it in
the context of have being fed up with
Muslims being here in the UK doing the
same things that they did historically
there to Christians. And you know, to
non-Muslims in general. So I always
thought the the irony, it just shows you
the unwavering continuity of this sort
of conflict between Muslims and
non-Muslims or Christians and Westerners
in this context.
And so the folks that are waving it, I'm
sure are very aware of the Crusades and
what it represents. So apparently, the
politicians know as well and they don't
want their Islamic benefactors in the UK
offended by this specific flag they're
picking up. I mean, they could pick up
the Union Jack, right? They're choosing
this flag to fly. I mean, there's a
reason why. You just explained it. So
isn't that something that the the uh
the folks in Great Britain are putting
it down? They're they're they're
persecuting their own people.
It has to be because these politicians
are either afraid of Islam or they're
being paid. They their NGOs, their their
campaigns, their re-election, they're
being paid. I mean, why else would you
betray your own people and homeland?
Oh, exactly. And
as I always say, you know, when you want
to answer these questions definitively,
ask yourself if the shoe is on the other
foot. Or in other words, who who else
does this?
But Europeans and Westerners. Can you
imagine a single country, whether Japan
or India or China or, you know, any
African country or Latin American
country, convicting and getting angry at
its citizens for being patriotic and
waving that nation's flag? That doesn't
happen. It only happens in the West.
Okay, and that that that itself really
speaks volumes to me about [snorts] the
nature of what's really going on here
and how it's really a sort of internal
subversion from especially the
politicians because really the buck
stops with them.
The rise of anti-Semitism.
I don't have to agree and I don't agree
with everything the government of Israel
does. You don't want to agree with
everything the my government does. But I
understand, particularly as a Christian,
what I see as
God's plan for the Jewish people and
what God has done with the Jewish
people. You know, helping, I believe, to
give us the Bible, inspired. But I think
God has a plan for many many of the
Jewish people as I as I study
the Bible.
But
I I preface that because I don't I'm not
saying the defense of the Israeli
government. I'm talking about the Jewish
people and fighting anti-Semitism and
the horrors of the Holocaust and all
that goes with that.
It seems though Americans, and maybe
people in the UK,
don't know or never taught about the
relationship between Hitler and the
Grand Mufti of Palestine. And that he
recruited some 10,000 Muslims to wear
the Nazi uniform.
It seems we're setting ourselves up in
the West here with Islam, which is so
tied to a hatred of Christians and Jews.
But yet, all we hear about is the Jews,
the Jews, the Jews. I have to wonder
at what point is this being funded by
the Islamists, this anti-Semitism? At
what point do I have to ask is it China?
Is it Russia? Is it other Iran that are
also funding some of this in order to
break us apart as a country? Or is it
Islamic money that's doing this so that
they can damage damage America and then
go after some of the the Jews worldwide
as well as Israel? Because when you
study this this
Holocaust, we know the Grand Mufti,
according to the Nuremberg trials, was
heavily involved as an architect of the
final solution.
And yet,
there's so little talk about that.
Makes me wonder how much these Islamic
countries are involved in influencing
our textbooks, our schools, our social
media to stir us up as a country and pit
us against each other.
Well, yeah, I mean, again, this is very
much connected to the question of money
and influence from Islamic countries.
Inasmuch as they have that money and
influence, you can expect whatever
agenda that serves them, in this case
Jew hatred, for instance, to be
promulgated and sort of disseminated.
That wouldn't be surprising at all. But
what I also find interesting and kind of
kind of alarming is, you know, whatever,
you know, there there seems to be this
weird dichotomy, which is kind of like
for the longest time it went by it went
like this. Israel is good. Therefore,
Muslims are bad. Or the flip side is
Muslims are bad, therefore Israel is
good. Now, inasmuch as Israel is is
coming under a lot of criticism, I'm
seeing the opposite, which is Israel is
bad, therefore Muslims are good.
And I think that's very dangerous way of
thinking because as you as you pointed
out, however one wants to think of
Israel and its political actions, etc.,
I don't think that in any way, shape or
form should sort of rehabilitate the
image of Islam in anyone's eyes. They're
not
they're not mutually exclusive
categories. You know, it's not like one
if one's good, the other's bad and if
the other is good, the other is bad. So
I would tell people that it you know,
during this entire process with all this
criticism against Israel, I'm seeing a
lot of sympathy for Islam in general.
And it's just not really warranted. I
think people need to separate the two
and see them, you know,
again, the Israel thing, that's not my
field. Okay, but Islam is. And I don't
think anyone should give it a pass
because they they have any kind of
because they're critical of Israel per
se. So that is definitely one kind of
sort of result that I've seen that I
find very interesting and somewhat
alarming. All right, in our closing time
together, let's talk a little bit about
your books. Here's one. Defenders of the
West.
The Christian Heroes Who Stood Against
Islam.
Tell me about
maybe England's Richard Lionheart and
some of these other folks.
Tell me what what they did
and why it should inspire us today.
And how does that influence you? And And
do you see any such figures
today in America or in Great Britain?
Yeah, so the nature of the book was
actually just to discuss the conflict.
My the first book before that, Sword and
Scimitar, looked at all these major
decisive battles between Christendom or
the West and Islam throughout history.
And in this book, I basically decided to
look at decisive men to show especially
Christians of the modern of the modern
West that, you know, you don't have to
always be a doormat. These Christians
that I identify and write about,
who were who were Crusaders or fought in
Crusades or even they're not, you know,
when a lot of them are from Hungary and
Romania. I even include Vlad Tepes
Tepish, the Impaler, Dracula, because
again, when you dig into the sources,
you find he's not just a pure monster.
He actually was a patriot who loved his
religion and his country and he just
fought fire with fire. And the desperate
means that he succumbed to is really
more a reflection of what was required
to fight the enemy, which were the
Muslims, the Turks in this case. But
it's good, I think that book is really
good because it shows especially
Christians who've sort of been taught
that they have to be doormats, that no,
there is a militant righteous militant
side. And it's in the nature of just
war. Okay, which isn't about aggression
or forcing people to become Christian.
It's about actually defending that which
is right and good and noble
including one's own homeland and family
and civilization and culture and
religion. Which to many people in the
West don't seem to be keen on doing. So
that was one of the main reasons I
wanted to write that book was just to
show that it wasn't always like this and
there was a time and that's the irony
that you know you if you read that book
you'll find that Europeans fought tooth
and nail to keep Islam out of Europe for
a reason. And now they're doing the
opposite the leaders the elected leaders
bringing Islam in by the millions and lo
and behold what are Muslims doing in
Europe? Well, the same sorts of things
that these guys in this book were trying
to fight and prevent from happening. So
you know definitely a sober lesson about
what happens when people forget history
which is that they repeat it. And here's
another one you wrote. Um Crucified
again exposing Islam's new war on
Christians. For many many years people
can go back into our vault and see that
one of the phrases I've been using is
that the globalist are using the
Islamist as junkyard dogs
to de-Christianize the West. They're
using the Islamist as junkyard dogs to
go after their enemies. And I think
that's happening. And I think they're
also using them uh to say after the
globalist stand back and watch hey we
got a problem. We have the extremist the
extremist Christians the extremist on
Islam the extremist on the Jews side
you know these are all the problems. And
we need to get people under control and
hate crime laws and we need to limit
free speech. And I have And then of
course you have the problem with
immigration. They flooded our country.
They flooded Great Britain.
And now we'll solve that immigration
crisis. Everybody needs to have
biometrics and be chipped and tagged
like cattle and then people can go to
and fro and we'll have safety and
security.
I think we're not done yet
with major terrorist attacks that I
think they'll let happen so that
Americans will go where they otherwise
would never agree to go. Being willing
to be tracked and tagged like cattle.
Can't let a good crisis go to waste
right? Speak to that how the how the
globalist have used Islam as this
battering ram to to uh
de-Christianize the West but also to get
people in the West to surrender to a
really a dystopian
well
new world order if you want to call it
that or the great reset.
Yeah, well definitely there's a lot of
you know plausibility what what you're
describing. You know they're bringing in
these millions of Muslims and on the one
hand you know Europeans need to cater to
them. They need to suppress they're told
suppress your religion suppress your
culture because you have to accommodate
you know the newcomer who of course is
inherently hostile to Christianity and
European culture anyway to start with
because they're Muslim. And you know
you're seeing violence and you're seeing
as I described when Muslims go on a
stabbing spree including killing little
children. Okay, which happens again with
a lot of frequency. And all of this is
again making a lot of of the normal
people in Europe very very angry. And
you know rallying around the St. George
flag is one thing but I do think that
yeah if they rise up if they try to do
anything I'm speaking about the native
Europeans that that will give the
government the pretext or the regimes to
actually crack down and like you said
yeah
it's the radical Muslims who are causing
problems but it's usually they're
they're going to use that as a pretext
when when when those who are provoked
and frustrated namely Europeans in this
case do anything then then it gets
multiple you know then that they're
demonized and all these laws to censor
and and and you know take away their
rights in the name of security will
happen and you know this goes all the
way back people often cite 9/11 to say
well look at uh you know look what how
much freedom and security rights we have
to give up because of that as well and
that was you know well over 20 years
ago. So now you have a whole continent
that's just flooded with Muslims and a
lot of frustrated and angry people and
then you have you know the puppet
masters above who are just waiting for
it all to come to a boil and then they
step in and you know declare peace at a
price of course which is uh the the
revocation of your freedoms. Indeed it
is. I hope you will go here take a look
folks. Raymond Ibrahim .com Just spell
his name out there you see it on the
screen. You can find out about his
books. You can get a signed copy of one
of his books.
Find all of his latest articles. Check
it all his YouTube. Check it all out
there. Raymond Ibrahim .com
I hope you'll come back Raymond. I've
been wanting to interview you for so
long and I'm so glad you're here and
you'll come back.
Sure I'd be happy to. Thanks Brandon.
Look forward to it. Raymond Ibrahim
checking in tonight folks.
Go to his website. Raymond Ibrahim .com
Um all right?